I want to begin with a very
brief quote by an individual
who takes up some
important space towards the,
towards the end
of the lecture.
This is by former U.S.
representative
Shirley Chisholm,
and she says,
"The emotional,
sexual, and psychological
stereotyping of female
begins when the doctor
says 'It's a girl.'" Now
throughout the course, in
an underlying sort of way,
every now and again,
we've been talking about,
in a variety of
different ways,
gender dynamics in
the American scene,
whether it's the strange
intermarriage--interesting
choice of
words--of race and,
and sex and gender, when it
comes to the figure of the
black male rapist, or
the black male brute,
and white womanhood,
vaunted womanhood.
And certainly we've been
hearing from our primary
sources especially, a range
of different women writers
and thinkers and activists.
Today I want to spend a lot
of the lecture focusing on,
on this particular moment
in the early 1970s where you
have a very modern
articulation of a new black
feminism.
So as you've been hearing
from me in the last several
lectures, it almost
sounds like a drumbeat,
I realize, that this
is a complicated area.
There's a lot of strife,
there's a lot of confusion.
Well, the fact
simply is that it,
that it is, and as
this lecture's covering
essentially the mid-1960s
up to the mid-1970s,
as we get into
the 1970s, there's,
there's no radical
change in the idea of social
complication.
It's a period of
profound unrest in the U.S.
The economic up--euphoria
of the 1960s--something I
didn't mention: the
economy's booming.
I mean, this is part of the,
the angry--the anger you
hear in Gil Scott-Heron, in
his spoken word performance,
"Whitey on the Moon."
It's like, we're spending
all this money sending--I
mean it's expensive to
pers--put a person on the
moon, as it turns out.
Yet in black America, we're
not seeing any of this,
this kind of benefit.
So the sixties are a period
of incredible economic
prosperity for many
parts of the United States.
For many black
urban dwellers,
though, it's
something quite different.
When you get into
the 1970s, though,
the economic
euphoria vanishes,
and a new fiscal
reality sets in that,
that, that forces
economists to think,
to rethink old
working models.
You know things are supposed
to act in a certain way.
My goodness, they're not
acting in a certain way.
And they actually
coined a phrase,
a term for the new economic
problems of the mid- and the
late-1970s.
That phrase is stagflation.
In a stagnant economy,
according to the models,
means that you're not
going to have inflation.
In fact, you
might have deflation.
But you had a stagnant
economy and inflation,
and it's something that just
hadn't happened before and
it sort of defied
a lot of the--of,
of logic, but, you know,
this is what happens when
new logic
models are proposed.
So fiscally, the country's
heading into a wreck.
It's also a period of
psychological trauma as far
as the mythological,
mythological purity of
America was concerned,
the atrocities of war,
and there's
always atrocities,
but now they're being
brought home for the first
time via the media's close
involvement in the war,
with the war in Vietnam.
I mean, you have cameras,
what we now--what we would
now call them?,
embedded, you know,
journalists.
You had cameras
in the field,
you--video and film, and the
images are coming back on
the nightly news, something
that we don't see any more,
frankly.
That, that has
been shut down.
And it's been shut
down because it was very
effective at
spreading dismay or anxiety,
what the heck we are
doing over in Vietnam.
Why do our young men keep
coming home in body bags?
So with a
heightened media presence,
means you can't hide
the fact that America's
overwhelming military
power found itself almost
irrelevant in the
face of North Vietnamese
determination.
The war is not going well,
as you get into the late
sixties and into
the early seventies.
You have a sitting president
in the late sixties,
LBJ, who declines to run
for a second term in office.
A shocking moment.
You know, he took over
when JFK was assassinated,
won a first election, then
had a chance to run for a
second, and said no.
The Republican
Party, under Nixon,
takes control with a
pledge to the South,
I mentioned in a
previous lecture,
with Strom Thurmond, that
is going to ignore the civil
rights gains of the
preceding decade.
Nixon runs on a law
and order campaign.
Actually, a few of you
came to Kathleen Cleaver's
presentation last night, and
she said something that's
really quite striking,
and I've heard it from many
different people.
And you'll, you'll hear it
from me in a different way I
suppose later on in this
course in the time that
remains, is that you
look for those people like
Kathleen Cleaver who were
adults during Nixon's era.
This is like, you know, the
country can't get any worse
as far as
presidential leadership.
But you look back
at--[Student sneezes] Bless
you--at the, at, at the
Republican party politics
under, under Nixon, and the
country has shifted very far
to the right, the
arbitrary right,
in terms of being much more
conservative politically,
that from the standpoint
of many different political
projects, Nixon is sounding
really quite progressive in
many areas
compared to--you know,
it doesn't matter
who's in the office,
Republican or Democrat.
Clinton was a conservative
Republican and Obama's a
moderate--excuse me.
What did I
say?--conservative Democrat
and, and Obama's a
moderate Democrat,
and Nixon on many issues,
they had--they were on the
same page, where Nixon was
a little bit more liberal.
It's, it's a weird
kind of thing to say,
but this is the record.
In any event,
Nixon's now in office,
running under a law
and order campaign,
having gotten
into office under,
running, running underneath
a law and order campaign.
But he's not in office
that long when the country's
growing skepticism
about its elected officials
intensifies, once it
learns about the break-in,
break-ins at the Watergate,
and the extent to which the
cover ups were orchestrated
by the White House,
by Nixon himself.
It's actually funny.
This is around--I
was born in 1967,
and I remember watching
live TV and thinking--well,
I thought Nixon
was the guy on the,
on the dime.
I didn't realize it was
a different President,
but the guy that looked
like the guy on the dime,
I knew he was in trouble.
I didn't know what he did,
and it was too much for my
small brain to
accommodate at the time,
but my first political
memory is of the impeachment
hearings, dealing
with, with Richard Nixon.
People were
fixated on the TV,
what is the
Congress going to do?
So growing out
of this moment,
we're talking here
the early 1970s,
the economy begins to tank,
the military is humiliated,
the political process
becomes tainted at the
highest levels
and the country's,
in a sense, is lost.
Now many African Americans
felt for a very long time
that the
country's innocence has,
had been lost long
before the 1970s.
Black women in particular
had an acute sense of
disdain at the country's
pronouncements about
equality before the law
and then the promise of the
civil rights movement.
Black women suffer from what
they called double jeopardy,
being black and
being female.
Citizenship twice denied.
For too long,
freedom was equated with,
in as far as the African
American community is
concerned, is equated
with black manhood and the
freedom of blacks, with
the redemption of black
masculinity.
If we can help our brothers,
then we'll all be free.
Elaine Brown becomes the
leader of the Black Panther
Party in the early 1970s,
once the founding leadership
is either
jailed, kicked out,
or in exile.
Elaine Brown recalled an
organizational meeting when
she and other women were
forced to wait to eat until
the men were served food
for which they all had
contributed.
The eth--ethos of
the time was that,
quote, this is Elaine
Brown speaking here,
"Sisters do not
challenge brothers.
Sisters stood
behind their black men,
supported their men,
and respected them."
So even in a vanguard
organization like the Black
Panthers, a group that
called for political and
economic reorientation in
American life and values,
good, old-fashioned
sexism is alive and well.
Sexism of course is nothing
new to the American scene.
What was new was a rising
articulation of modern
feminism that is built upon
the emotional power of the
civil rights movement.
I imagine you've heard it
many times before that you
look at the great
changes in women's politics,
Chicano,
Lat--Latino politics,
Asian America
politics, LGBTQ politics,
they're growing out of the
organizational skills really
mastered by civil
rights activists,
women's, women's
movement being the most,
the earliest sort of,
quote, other movement,
building upon models of the
civil rights movement with
great success.
In 1963, Betty Friedan
published The Feminine
Mystique.
It became a
tremendously important book,
and it was essentially
about how to get white,
middle-class women out
of the home and into the
workplace.
Without diminishing the
importance of the book,
it's, it's a landmark book.
For black women,
the book seemed,
from sort of an
argumentative standpoint,
largely irrelevant, because
black women had always been
out of the home, in someone
else's home actually,
often as domestics.
But they didn't have the
leisure and the opportunity
to be at home in a way that
white middle-class women
did.
It's from an
economic standpoint.
So The Feminine
Mys--Mystique is one of the
first volleys of what
will become sort of modern
feminist movement, and
right at the very beginning,
black women are wondering,
"Well where--How does this
book apply to
my experience?"
A couple of
years later in 1965,
black women and their sense
of being ignored by major
currents in American society
are turned on its head in a
weird way when they
find themselves with the
spotlight turned on them.
Black women used
to being ignored,
and now the
spotlight's on them,
only this time they're not
being blamed--only this time
they're being
blamed, excuse me,
for black
America's failures.
At that moment,
Daniel Patrick Moynihan,
future senator, then part
of the Department of Labor,
published a report called
The Negro Family: The Case
for National Action.
The report had charted black
life in the United States.
It spoke about the
economic, political,
and social deprivations
that grew out of slavery and
explored how being a
disadvantaged minority
affected the black
family structure.
Today, it's a tremendously
important report,
and it sets welfare policy
standards for the next
generation.
I want to reduce the report
to its simplest and most
controversial essence.
Although
Moynihan lamented it,
he said he felt that, he
felt that there was nothing,
nothing else to do but
conclude that blacks were
caught in a, quote,
"tangle of pathology."
It's an important phrase.
This tangle, moreover, was
a result of women-headed
households in black America.
To illustrate this logic,
I'm going to quote from the
text, and I want you to
listen here for the very
clear investment in the
norm of patriarchy here.
Moynihan writes: "That the
Negro American has survived
at all is extraordinary--a
lesser people might simply
have died out, as
indeed others have.
That the Negro community
has not only survived,
but in this political
generation has entered
national affairs
as a moderate,
humane, and constructive
national force is the
highest testament to
the healing powers of the
democratic ideal and the
creative vitality of the
negro people.
But it may not be supposed
that the Negro American
community has not paid
a fearful price for the
incredible mistreatment to
which it has been subjected
over the past
three centuries.
In essence, the Negro
community has been forced
into a matriarchal
structure which,
because it is so out of
line with the rest of the
American society, seriously
retards the progress of the
group as a whole, and
imposes a crushing burden on
the Negro male
and, in consequence,
on a great many
Negro women as well.
There is, presumably,
no special place--no,
excuse me, no special reason
why a society in which males
are dominant in family
relationships is to be
preferred to a
matriarchal arrangement.
However, it is clearly a
disadvantage for a minority
group to be
operating on one principle,
while the great
majority of the population,
and the one with the most
advantages to begin with,
is operating on another.
This is the present
situation of the Negro.
Ours is a society which
presumes male leadership in
private and public affairs.
The arrangements of society
facilitate such leadership
and reward it.
A subculture, such as
that of the Negro American,
in which this is not--in
which this is not the
pattern, is placed at a
distinct disadvantage.
Here an earlier word
of caution is--should,
should be repeated.
There is much evidence that
a considerable amount--There
is much evidence that a
considerable number of Negro
families have managed to
break out of the tangle of
pathology and to establish
themselves as stable,
effective units, living
according to patterns of
American
society in general."
This is one excerpt
from a much larger study,
of course, and this is
coming from an old-fashioned
Democrat, an old--a, a great
liberal in the American
tradition, lamenting the
destruction of the black
family, pointing to the
fact that its matriarchal
structure, the
women-headed households,
is the real reason behind,
behind blacks' inability to
have successful
family units,
because it's so out of line
with the national norm of
male-headed households.
You know, it's great that
blacks are so--have such
strong backbones, they've
been able to survive so much
degradation, but we've got
to find a way to solve this
problem.
It is a call for
national action,
which is the subtitle, The
Case for National Action,
the subtitle of the report.
We need to solve the problem
of the structure of the
black family.
Black Americans are outraged
by the report and its claim
of an almost
organic dysfunctionalism.
This is not an anger that
sought to deny the very
obvious reality of poverty
in the black community.
No one could deny that.
And also this anger is not a
direct manifestation of the
failure of
Johnson's Great Society,
and King's civil rights
strategies to address
abiding problems of poverty.
People recognize the efforts
that are being made in these
regards.
The anger is really a
result of being considered a
problem that America, and
especially white America,
had to solve.
I mean think of this moment.
This is the moment
we're talking about.
Moynihan's report
comes out in '65.
Stokely Carmichael is
talking about Black Power in
'66, and while
Stokely Carmichael and,
and his fellow travelers
are a minority within black
America, they're still
getting a lot of attention,
far more attention than
their actual numbers would
suggest.
And to suggest--to hear then
from an important figure in
the federal
government, saying,
you know, "White Americans
really have to solve this
problem for black Americans.
We need to find a solution,"
and sort of saying,
you know, "It's
really too bad,
we've also been
part of the problem,
but we really can't
address that issue.
Let's try to fix
this black family,
just outraged
black, black Americans.
So according to Moynihan,
blacks are a problem that
white America
had to resolve.
Now you may or may
not be surprised,
as I've talked in this
course about connections to
events decades earlier
and the way in which things
don't change at times.
You may not be
surprised that W.
E.
B.
Du Bois, having just passed
away two years earlier,
said as much the
same thing in 1903,
when he offered the
following words in his
landmark book, The
Souls of Black Folk.
And Du Bois said, "Between
me and the other world there
is an ever unasked question:
unasked by some through
feelings of delicacy;
by others through the
difficulty of
rightly framing it.
All, nevertheless,
flutter around it.
They approach me in a
half-hesitant sort of way,
eye me curiously
or compassionately,
and then, instead
of saying directly,
'How does it feel to be
a problem?' they say,
'I know an excellent
colored man in my town;
or, 'Do not these southern
outrages make you--make your
blood boil?' At
these I smile,
or am interested, or reduce
the boiling to a simmer,
as the occasion may require.
To the real question,
'How does it feel to be a
problem?' I
answer seldom a word."
This is a
different age, 1965.
This is a different age
than Du Bois's in 1903.
And instead of silence,
black women begin to be
heard on these kinds of
issues that Moynihan's
raising.
Now please note, I'm not
saying they begin to speak
up.
They're
beginning to be heard.
In the wake of the
Moynihan Report,
groups across the country,
individuals and groups,
galvanize into action.
There's a huge amount of
scholarship published in the
wake of the Moynihan Report,
in response to the Moynihan
Report, dealing with the
sociology of the black
family and, sort of,
so-called black sociology.
But on the activist front,
people are outraged by sort
of the blinders on Daniel
Patrick Moynihan's opinions
or thoughts or analyses,
start forming groups of
their own, and one of the
key players in this process
was a woman named
Johnnie Tillman,
a black woman, who had
been on welfare herself,
who helped organize
the National Welfare
Organization, the NWRO.
Tillman becomes one of the
galvanizing figures of the
NWRO, and really one
of its spokespersons.
Tillman defined poverty as
the defining element in the
lives of black women.
Through her
leadership at the NWRO,
she pursued a practical
agenda that called for
decent wages, access to
education and job training,
medical care for
women children,
and children's daycare.
They want decent wages,
access to education and job
training, medical care
for women and children,
and children's daycare.
And the NR--excuse me, the
NWRO also called for an end
to abusive and degrading
practices of welfare case
workers who
would, for example,
show up at a welfare
recipient's home at
midnight, looking for
evidence of other means of
support.
And most often, quote,
"other means of support,
meant that an
adult male was present.
It was built into the
structure of welfare policy
of this era that
suggestion--you see in
Moynihan's ideology--that
the norm should be
patriarchal-headed
family structure.
That if there
was a man around,
it became much harder for a
person on welfare to be able
to claim that welfare.
Tillman made her
dissatisfaction known in
public rallies
across the country.
The title of one of her
more frequent talks was,
was "Welfare is a
Woman's Issue."
It's a piece that ran
in--that would eventually
run in Gloria Steinem's
breakout publication Ms.¸
published in 1972.
I want to read an
excerpt from that essay,
a version of which she gave
at many different rallies
across the country.
"Welfare is a
Woman's Issue,
by Johnnie Tillman.
"I'm a woman.
I'm a black woman.
I'm a poor woman.
I'm a fat woman.
I'm a middle-aged woman.
And I'm on welfare.
In this country, if you're
any one of those things,
you count less
as a human being.
If you're all those things,
you don't count at all,
except as a statistic.
I am forty-five years old.
I have raised six children.
There are millions of
statistics like me,
some on welfare, some not.
And some really poor, who
don't even know they're
entitled to welfare.
Not all of them in
black--are black,
not all--not at all.
In fact, the majority,
about two-thirds of all poor
families in the
country, are white.
"Welfare's like a
traffic accident.
It can happen to anybody,
but especially it happens to
women.
And that's why
welfare is a women's issue.
For a lot of middle-class
women in this country,
women's liberation is
a matter of concern.
For women on welfare,
it's a matter of survival.
Survival.
That's why we had
to go on welfare,
and that's why we
can't get off welfare now,
not us women.
Not until we do something
about liberating poor women,
women in this country,
because up until now,
we've been raised to expect
to work all our lives for
nothing, because we
are the worst educated,
the least skilled, and the
lowest paid people there
are; because we have to be
almost totally responsible
for our children; because we
are regarded by everybody as
dependents.
That's why we
are on welfare,
and that's why
we stay on it.
"Welfare is the most
prejudiced institution in
this country, even
more than marriage,
when it--which it
tries to imitate.
Let me explain
that a little.
Ninety-nine percent of
welfare families are headed
by women.
There is no man around.
In half the states
there can't be a man around
because AFDC (Aid to
Families With Dependent
Children) says if there is
an "able-bodied" man around,
then you can't
be on welfare.
If the kids are
going to eat,
and the man can't get a
job, then he's got to go.
Welfare is like a
super-sexist marriage.
You trade in a
man for the man.
But you can't divorce
him if he treats you bad.
He can divorce
you, of course,
cut you off
anytime he wants.
But in that case,
he keeps the kids,
not you.
The man runs everything.
In ordinary marriage, sex
is supposed to be for your
husband.
On AFDC, you're not supposed
to have any sex at all.
You give up control
of your own body.
It's a condition of aid.
You may even have to agree
to get your tubes tied so
you can never have more
children just to avoid being
cut off welfare.
The man, the welfare
system, controls your money.
He tells you what to
buy, what not to buy,
where to buy it, and
how much things cost.
If things,
rent, for instance,
really cost more
than he says they do,
it's just too bad for you.
He's always right.
That's why Governor Ronald
Reagan can get away with
slandering
welfare recipients,
calling them,
quote, "lazy parasites,
"pigs at the
trough," and such.
We've been trained to
believe that the only reason
people are on welfare is
because there's nothing
wrong with their character.
We've been trained to
believe that the only reason
people are on welfare is
because there's something
wrong with their character.
If people have motivation,
if people only want to work,
they can, and they will be
able to support themselves
and their kids in decency.
"The truth is a job doesn't
necessarily mean an adequate
income.
There are some ten million
jobs that now pay less than
the minimum wage,
and if you're a woman,
you've got the best
chance of getting one.
Why would a
forty-five-year-old woman
work all day in a
laundry ironing shirts at
ninety-some cents an hour?
Because she knows that
there's some place lower she
could be.
She could be on welfare.
Society needs women on
welfare as examples to let
every woman, factory workers
and housewife workers alike,
know what will
happen if she lets up.
If she's laid off, if she
tries to go it alone without
a man.
Society needs women on
welfare as examples to let
every woman, factory workers
and housewife workers alike,
know what will
happen if she lets up,
if, if she's laid off, if
she tries to go it alone
without a man.
So these ladies stay on
their feet or on their knees
all their lives instead
of asking why they're only
getting
ninety-some cents an hour,
instead of daring to
fight and complain."
Tillman carries this
drumbeat with her to public
rallies but also to
private meetings.
When, in 1968, she meets
with Martin Luther King
about welfare issues,
she grows increasingly
frustrated with
King's interruptions and,
in her view, evasions.
She goes to King
thinking, you know,
"Here's a man who's really
pledging himself to poverty
reform or economic
reform, addressing poverty,
and then realizes that
she's running into a stone
wall in many ways.
And finally
Tillman says to King,
"You know, Dr. King, if you
don't know anything about
these questions, you
should say you don't know,
and then we can go
on with the meeting."
King was, like everybody
is--and it's a meaningless
phrase--"a man of his
time," but his own notion of
patriarchal order was
certainly well in place.
Now Tillman and other NWRO
activists linked welfare
rights to civil rights,
explaining that being on
welfare was a necessity
borne of the economic
system, not of
women's moral failings.
So as where
Moynihan and the,
the Moy--the so-called
Moynihan Report is talking
about structures of
degradation and such,
it is being driven by a
moral assessment of women's
role in the black family.
And the NWRO takes out that
moral assessment and looks
at the structures of
economic exploitation and,
and lack of
education and such.
Now the NWRO represents one
type of political thrust of
the nine--late
1960s and early 1970s.
It's important that we
not lose sight of this
grassroots
rallies and activism,
calling for structural
changes when it comes to
welfare, but it's also
important to make note of a
few different milestones
in the world of politics.
This is the detour
that leads us to Shirley
Chisholm.
Now I spoke earlier about
the fact when the Civil
Rights Act became law, that
there's this moment of great
excitement, but
very quickly,
people understood it didn't
address voting issues,
and this was the real next,
this was the next frontier.
You'll also remember that
when I talked about the
Voting Rights
Act becoming law,
of course there were riots
a few days later in Los
Angeles, but looking
ahead a few years,
towards the end
of the sixites,
I said you would see a
radical change in the
numbers of voters.
The Voting Rights Act,
for all of its flaws of
implementation
and enforcement,
did bear witness to a
radical shift in the number
of blacks who were now able
to get access to the ballot
box.
And you start
seeing that change,
or you start seeing a change
based on the number of
blacks who were voting.
1967 was a landmark moment
in terms of voting behaviors
and it's actually only
tangential--tangentially
related, related to
the Voting Rights Act,
actually.
The story
unfolds in Cleveland.
Carl Stokes, a black man, is
elected mayor of the city.
He'd been a local figure for
some time and member of the
police force, very
prominent certainly.
He's not the first
black mayor ever,
but he's the first black
mayor--first black elected
mayor of a major city.
Now what's critically
important to think about in
Stokes's case is that blacks
are actually the minority of
the population in Cleveland.
[Student sneezes] Bless you.
Stokes becomes really the
first successful coalition
politician at that level
in the country's history.
He runs on a strong law and
order campaign that appealed
to a real segment
of the population,
conservative and
liberal, certainly.
You know, leans on his past
record as a police officer.
He appeals to the black
community simply because
here's a black man who's
going to stand up and,
and the assumption is
he's going to speak for us,
on our behalf.
But he really pulls in
liberal whites as well,
and through a
complicated sort of dance,
forms a coalition,
white and black voters,
becomes the mayor.
His campaign is
watched very closely,
and it becomes a model
for other black mayoralty
campaigns
across the country.
You start seeing
black mayors popping out.
Gary, Indiana,
just around the bend,
in Los Angeles,
California, soon enough.
You start seeing the
beginnings of the era of the
black mayor, in
our urban landscape.
And as the
voting rights--the,
the voting numbers start
to skyrocket for African
Americans, you start seeing
blacks elected to offices
in, in regions of the
country they had not ever
been elected,
largely in the Southeast.
Two years after Carl Stokes
is elected the mayor of
Cleveland, you
actually have,
as a result of an increasing
number of blacks going to
Congress, a new group formed
called the Congressional
Black Caucus, still
alive and very well today.
The
Congressional Black Caucus,
the CBC, is formed.
And essentially now we
have a critical mass,
still on the small
side, but a critical mass,
of black elected officials,
House representatives,
and then one in the
Senate at that time,
who are going to come
together on agendas that we
think we share--on which
we share common ground.
Will they always
be race agendas?
Ah, you know, I guess
that's the presumption,
but there could be common
ground on other issues.
It will form like a
political action group.
That's essentially
what the caucus is.
So you have a rising
number of people who are
in--holding positions of
power in formal elected
offices, and you have the
continuation of grassroots
activism on the ground.
In 1972, and as the
snowball's rolling down the
mountain, a number of
activists and elected
officials get
together, saying,
you know, "We've got a real
moment of opportunity here.
We're calling for change."
There are groups
like the NWRO,
not just--that's not
an all-black group;
I should have
made that clear,
it's a multiracial group.
But you have this
group on the ground,
other groups like
that on the ground,
small political
action groups in,
in cities
across the country.
You have black
militants, certainly.
You have still the
black leaders of churches.
That's been there
for a long time.
But now you have these
black mayors and these black
elected officials and,
and House representatives.
Here's a moment where we
need to take advantage of,
of our collective experience
as African Americans,
come together and try
to forge a new voice,
a new black political voice.
So they call
for a convention.
The National Black Political
Convention is held in 1972
in Gary, Indiana.
It's a meeting of
black radicals,
nationalists, and
mainstream politicians,
and it has the convention
theme of "Unity Without
Uniformity."
And this is now where I
spend a couple of minutes
reading excerpts from the,
from the platform and from
Amiri Baraka, a
radical black poet,
from his poem called
"It's Nation Time,
that is rather an
aggressive assertion of
black militancy and
black nationalism.
And I'll read
these two excerpts,
trust me on this,
where you have,
you know, this, this--and,
and Baraka's one of the
organizers of
this, of this meeting.
He had this very ardent
black militant voice,
you know, with a poem
laced with shotguns,
and racial
epithets, and, and,
and challenges to religious
orthodoxies that "it's
nation time,
it's nation time,
is really, you know, what
this--he's calling for in
the poem.
And you have the
host of the convention,
like Gary Hatcher,
mayor of--it's not Gary
Hatcher--the Mayor
Hatcher of Gary,
Indiana, Richard
Hatcher, saying,
"Look, we've got to
find a way to bridge the
differences," because
he's not going to stand on a
platform of--and I'm
paraphrasing from Baraka's
phone--poem,
"Niggers get your guns."
He's not going to
stand on that platform.
We don't want to lose this
opportunity--this organizing
opportunity, and emphasizes,
"We need to have unity and
understand we
cannot be uniform,
harking back to the
organizing theme of the
conference.
Now the National Black
Political Convention,
what does it leave us with?
It leaves with
no clear message.
Think back to the
National Negro Congress,
some forty--thirty-five,
thirty-six years earlier,
same kind of situation where
the coalition of different
kinds of black
voices come together,
with an unclear result.
But now these people
are elected into office.
The National Black Political
Convention exposes the
diversity of political
opinions within black
America.
It does that.
And a group grows out of it,
the National Black Political
Assembly.
And some thought that the
National Black Political
Assembly--essentially
like the Congressional Black
Caucus, but now operating
at all levels of political
organization in society,
grassroots up to the House
of Representatives--some
thought that this was an
incredible, going
to be an incredible,
incredible vehicle to
create real change.
And one of the people who
thought it was going to
create change was
Shirley Chisholm,
representative
from Brooklyn,
and the first woman to
represent New York state in
the U.S.
Congress.
Chisholm has just declared
her candidacy for the
presidency of the United
States and looked to the
activists involved in
the Gary convention,
the National Black
Political Convention,
looked to the activists at
the convention for their
support.
Chisholm's growing out of
the tradition now of someone
like Carl Stokes.
She's a real
coalition politician.
She was--this was rad--this
was controversial at the
time, she was a very public
member of the National
Organization for Women, a
group that black feminists
thought was just
for white women,
something I'll get to a
little bit later on as I
close out the lecture.
So Shirley Chisholm has a
whole bunch of support,
it seems, from people
like Gloria Steinem,
who published Johnnie
Tillman's essay about
welfare.
But then something funny
happens--not funny ha-ha,
funny unfortunate--is that
as Chisholm goes around the
floor of the
Gary convention,
as she starts seeking
support from her white
feminist friends, the cold,
hard reality of politics
invaded.
Black elected officials
distanced themselves
immediately from Chisholm,
because they believed that
her president--her
presidential campaign was an
absolute--an
absolute long shot,
and they wanted to align
themselves with more likely
Democratic contenders
for the national party's
nomination.
A crushing blow comes from
Chisholm when she overhears,
at another black
political conference,
these two officials.
She's--I guess she's
just within earshot.
One of them
says to the other,
two black men,
"There she is.
That little black matriarch
who goes around messing
things up."
So you have rising black
political organizations in
the high form of
politics, a connection,
it seems, to the grassroots
activism that you see in
groups like the NWRO.
Shirley Chisholm
tapping into this moment,
like this will be the moment
we can really forge change
in this country.
And like someone--I mean
Chisholm wasn't running on a
women's platform, per
se; she's running on,
running on a liberal
politics platform,
but she was seen as
unelectable by black elected
officials, and also by the
women in groups like NOW.
They cast their support
to the more mainstream,
quote, "mainstream"
Democratic contenders.
So Shirley Chisholm seems
as a complete affirmation of
this double jeopardy status
of black women in the United
States.
You know,
because she's black,
she's going to
be discounted,
because she's a woman, she's
going to be discounted.
Just depends on who's
doing the discounting.
And Chisholm wasn't the only
person to feel this way.
In 1973, a year after the
National Black Political
Convention, a group is
formed called the National
Black Feminist
Organization, the NBFO.
And it sets about to
criticize the stereotypes of
black women, criticize
the country for caring more
about black men.
As long as the
brothers are taken care of,
the sisters will be
taken care of eventually.
The NBFO activists took
issue with the media for
imposing standards of
beauty that are purely
Anglo--Anglophile.
The NBFO addressed
practical issues,
like the NRO--NWRO
did, like child welfare,
unemployment, etcetera.
And it, the, the National
Black Feminist Organization
added, in its ideology,
something that had really
been solely the domain of
white feminist movement to
that point, namely abortion
rights and equal rights
amendment.
It is an organization
with an ideologically broad
umbrella on feminist issues,
broader in its opinion than
the National
Organization for Women.
Now the NBFO,
perhaps predictably,
was met with a
strong backlash.
It was accused of hampering
the black movement,
in air quotes,
"the black movement,
is accused of hampering it.
You know, getting people
confused about what's the
real voice of black America.
Is accused of
being man-hating,
in part--in large part
because it welcomed lesbians
into its
organizations, publicly.
Now all of the
NBFO collapses,
almost as quickly
as it's formed.
It does not last long.
It exposed a range of hot
button issues within the
black community and inspired
other groups to form,
most famously, the
Combahee River Collective.
I want to turn quickly
to the Combahee River
Collective statement,
the collective statement,
and point, to some--point
to some of these hot button
issues.
The statement reads that,
"We are a collective of
black feminists who have
been meeting together since
1974, involved in the
process of defining and
clarifying our politics,
while doing political work
within our own group and
in coalition with other
progressive
organizations and movements.
We see black feminism as the
logical political movement
to combat the manifold and
simultaneous oppression that
all women of color face."
It goes into the genesis of
contemporary black feminism,
and then has three
points of what we believe,
the problems in
organizing black feminists,
and black feminist
issues and projects.
And I'm excerpting here.
"What We Believe,"
the statement says,
"Although we are
feminists and lesbians,
we feel solidarity with
progressive black men and do
not advocate the
fractionalization that white
women who are
separatists demand.
We struggle together with
black men against racism,
while we also struggle
with black men about sexism.
We are socialists because
we believe that work must be
organized for the collective
benefit of those who do the
work and create
the products,
and not for the
profit of the bosses.
We need to articulate the
real class situation of,
of persons for whom racial
and sexual oppression are
significant determinants
in their working,
economic lives."
Calling on the recognition
of problems in organizing
black feminists, the
Combahee River Collective
says that, "The major
source of difficulty in our
political work is that we
are trying to address a
whole range of oppressions.
We are dispossessed
psychologically and on every
other level, and yet we feel
the necessity to struggle to
change the condition
of all black women.
If black women were free,
it would mean that everyone
else would have to be free,
since our freedom would
necessitate the destruction
of all the systems of
oppression."
Again, that notion
of multiple forms of,
of oppression weighing
down on blackness and,
and
female--women, womanhood.
And it says in terms of
"Black Feminist Issues and
Projects," is one of the,
"One issue that is of major
concern to us, and that
we have begun to publicly
address, is racism in the
white women's movement."
I made reference
to this earlier,
Shirley Chisholm's sort of
confront--what am I looking?
Wow, just completely drew
a blank on a very basic
word--controversial, on her
controversial membership in
the National
Organization for Women.
In the
successful rise of the,
the feminist movement, black
women start telling stories
of trying to affiliate with
what are essentially white
groups.
And the stories they start
to tell are rather--stories
of great
frustration, and they,
they're, they replicate
themselves constantly.
Black woman going into a
meeting of local N--NOW
activists and having her
voice being the only voice
that's silenced, or
having black organization,
a women's organization,
trying to affiliate with the
white women's organization,
and the white activists
trying to take over the
black women's organization.
Presump--presumption
of who knows best.
So the Combahee
River Collective,
the National Black Feminist
Organization before it as
well, and people
like Shirley Chisholm,
all recognizing that
there is something flawed,
even in women's
rights organizations,
and it's, it's
the racial dynamic.
So you have a rising sense
of black feminist political
awareness and determination
to change the conversation.
Shirley Chisholm was
certainly frustrated,
but she's
committed to change.
In this era, on
the political front,
you see a reflection of
that commitment to change,
where the number of
black women who are elected
officials skyrockets from
fifteen percent of the black
elected officials are
women in the late sixties,
to nearly sixty percent
by the end of the 1970s.
A humongous change in
who's representing this
constituency, presumptively
but not always representing
a black constituency.
Now as I did on Monday,
I was talking about the
incredible cultural
power of the moment,
and the interesting
narratives of misogyny and
hyper-masculinity you see
in blaxploitation films.
This is also an era that
you see the beginning of an
incredible renaissance in
black women's literature
especially.
The great author Toni
Morrison appearing on the
scene with The
Bluest Eye in 1970.
Alice Walker, who would
become most famous for
writing Colored--ha-ha,
I just noticed here,
in my typing
these notes here,
I wrote, I wrote Colored
People--The Color Purple.
Just noticed
that big old typo.
Anyway, Alice Walker, who
published that book in 1982,
but in the seventies, she
was doing an incredible
amount of recovery work.
For example, who's, who
here has heard of Zora Neale
Hurston?
I mean pretty
much everybody.
None of your hands would
have gone up prior to the
nine--early 1970s.
And the hands are being
raised now because of Alice
Walker's,
essentially, detective work.
She makes it her
mission, for example,
to discover Zora
Neale Hurston's grave,
unmarked.
Zora Neale Hurston had this
incredible moment in the,
in the late
thirties and forties,
but disappears.
She dies penniless,
she's working as a maid,
her writing disappears.
Alice Walker discovers
it and makes an attempt,
a concerted effort, to bring
her back into the literary
conversation in
American letters,
and does it
quite successfully.
And she's recognizing,
Alice Walker is,
in this recuperative work,
dealing with Zora Neale
Hurston, that
this new voice,
or in Zora Neale
Hurston's case,
an older voice, but a new
way of listening to this
voice.
It's about black women who
wanted to declare political
engagement on
their own terms,
not men's, not black men's,
and not white women's.
And Walker calls for a new
term that would apply to
black women in general
and that's womanist.
A womanist politics is a
black feminist politics.
Walker, when asked to
comment on the combination
of events over the previous
decades that open up the
possibilities
for black women,
she said, speaking
of her characters,
said "My women in the future
will not burn themselves up.
Now I am ready to look at
women who have made the room
larger for
others to move in.
I think one reason I never
stay away from the southern
movement is because I
realize how deeply political
changes affect the choices
and lifestyles of people.
The movement of the
sixties, Black Power,
the Muslims, the Panthers,
have changed the options of
black people generally
and of black women in
particular, so that my women
characters won't all end the
way they have been, because
black women now offer the
varied, live models of
how it is possible to live.
We have a new
place to move."
And move they did.
We will pick up
discussion on next Monday.
Thank you.